We saved it for the last minute to go,
oh, maybe we should call a data vendor
and see if we can subscribe
to some of these data feeds,
which was an absolutely deadly mistake.
Rachel Carpenter, thank you so much
for being on my show.
How are you?
I'm great.
How are you doing?
Thanks for having me.
Of course, it's great to have you.
I'm very excited to hear about
the story of Intrinio.
And going, I think,
all the way back to 2012, right?
I heard you on another podcast mentioned
starting out in a pretty interesting way
and going through the journey
of understanding
the different limitations
and working in the
financial services space
and running a high tech company.
But let's go all the way
to the beginning.
Who is Rachel Carpenter
and why start a high tech venture?
Great question.
Rachel Carpenter was actually
originally a musical theater major.
Believe it or not.
Ended up founding a data company,
which is a wide swing.
But I grew up in Wisconsin.
And I went to
University of Wisconsin, Madison.
And I ended up getting dual degrees
in finance and entrepreneurship.
And
part of what I went through in college
was recognizing that I never wanted
to work for somebody else ever again.
In my entire life.
I had a pretty bad college level job.
So, I knew I wanted
to be an entrepreneur.
I didn't know exactly
what I wanted to do yet.
And so, I met my co-founder
while I was in college.
He was a CPA and I was studying finance.
So, we had a lot of background
in that space.
And the original business concept
that we decided to go after
was actually an online valuation engine.
So, to do business valuations
and assess business model,
we wanted to build the software online.
Where to start,
you would just kind of type in a ticker
of any stock you were interested in
and it would tell you,
it would run a valuation
and then tell you,
is the stock overvalued, undervalued,
Is it a strong buy or sell.
We wanted to kind
of build this stock app,
this investing tool.
And so, I came from a background
that was not technical at all.
But I'd always loved math
and I kind of fell in love with finance
because of that.
And that's why I studied that.
So, part of it what we went through
was recognizing this is very complex.
If we are going to build
a stock app like this,
we probably need to learn how to program
to get it off the ground on our own.
And so, I took a year,
and between my co-founder and I,
we learned Ruby for the back end
and some of the front end
programming languages
that we needed to get this thing built.
And so, I went through this journey
of teaching myself how to program.
I was sleeping on a couch.
We were making no money.
It was very uncomfortable.
And we ended up building this thing.
The problem was that
we were illegally screen scraping data
from ten thousand websites.
Wait. So, before we get
we get into all this illegal fun stuff,
that decision to go
and teach yourself how to program,
you and your co-founder,
it's very unusual.
In the sense that
a lot of the stories that I hear
and that I meet are entrepreneurs.
They might not even be coming
from the tech background
or the computer science background,
but they have this great idea
that could be a software solution,
and then they go and they find people
to build that for them,
but they don't necessarily
teach themselves how to code.
I'm a coder myself,
and I advocate for learning how to code.
But tell me about that,
that critical moment
where you're deciding to take
that whole year,
a very expensive year.
Not just because
you're not making any money,
but because you want to get moving
with your ideas
and you're choosing to teach yourself
how to code.
Yeah, that's a great question.
And I tend to honestly not recommend it
in most cases.
I mean, you know this, right?
It takes a decade plus
to really become a proficient engineer.
And with most technology startups,
you have a short window
to really beat the competition
and get your product off the ground
so you don't have time typically
to do that.
And in nine out of ten cases,
I would say, don't learn how to program,
go find a technical co-founder,
go find a team that can do it for you.
Because you would be surprised
how long it takes
to get really, really good.
And I didn't get there.
I got dangerous enough
to get this thing together.
But my CTO today still tells me
he's like when I took over, it was
there was just skeletons left and right
underneath the rug
with the kind of code that I was writing.
Because I wasn't classically trained
and I only had a year under my belt.
So, I don't recommend it in most cases.
I think in our case,
what we were building
was so iterative and we didn't know
where we were going to end up with it.
And it was so financially complex.
Understanding how to do
a discounted cash flow is hard enough
with just financial knowledge.
And then figuring out
how to program that
and turn it into an app
is a whole different story.
And so, in rare cases, I think,
if the area that you're working in
is super complex
and requires domain expertise,
it can make sense
and you can actually move faster.
In our case, like we would have literally
had to have had a CPA
over the shoulder of an engineer.
And that doesn't work very smoothly.
So, there's unique cases like ours
where it did make sense.
The caveat there is that
I had to give it up eventually.
Once we got this thing to the point
where we were moving,
we hired engineers
who had tons of experience
and could really take it
to the next level.
So, if you are in the one out of ten
where it makes sense to learn,
you do have to recognize
that you have to give it up, eventually.
Right. Okay.
So, it's 2012,
and now you're running this
iterative business,
you're figuring stuff out along the way
and you've reach the first roadblock
where you find that you're
illegally scraping data online.
So, talk to me about that junction now.
Yeah.
So, any application you're going to build
in the FinTech space,
the raw materials of that industry
are data, right?
I mean, everything runs off of data.
We needed stock prices,
financial statements, earnings estimates,
economic data comps,
we need it for all the stocks
in the universe of the United States.
And so, you know,
places like Yahoo! Finance
or different companies like that
to kind of scrape things down.
But that's it,
you can't publish a product that way
because there's terms of service.
And so, we were,
we were kind of scraping for a while
to get our prototype built.
But when we really wanted
to launch this thing publicly,
we saved it for the last minute to go,
oh, maybe we should call a data vendor
and see if we can subscribe
to some of these data feeds,
which was an absolutely deadly mistake,
because the companies that we had to call
were Bloomberg, Capital IQ,
Thomson Reuters,
these huge, huge companies.
And to put it in perspective,
for the data that we needed
to launch our app,
it was going to cost anywhere between
60 and $70,000 a month to get started.
So, remember, I'm on a couch.
I have no money.
I've just spent this horrible year
draining myself through the dirt,
trying to get started.
It ended everything for us instantly.
There are no economics that work out
for a startup at that stage
to even raise money enough to support
a $70,000 a month data expense.
So, we were pretty pissed off.
To be honest.
It was not a fun day.
So, you find yourself
with your co-founder.
It's been a year of struggling
and running this iterative business.
You finally reach some sort of product
that you're happy with
and you're going to these data vendors.
So, what's next?
Did you just give up?
Do you pivot?
Where do you go from there?
We got mad.
Which was a good place to be.
And sometimes, that can be the best start
of something even better.
We got really, really angry,
about all the time we had spent.
And so, the analogy
that I use to describe
this point in the journey is that
we realized,
do we want to be in the car business
or do we want to be in the gas business.
Because that's a big choice to make.
We've recognized here,
anybody that wants to build a car
or a FinTech app or some type of solution
for financial services,
they're going to need fuel.
It's going to be data.
But if it's that expensive
and that restrictive for us
to get our hands on it,
maybe we've uncovered
a much bigger problem here.
An opportunity to kind of reinvent
the supply chain of how those data feeds
are made available.
And so, there was kind of
two things that happened.
We realized,
maybe we should think about data
as a business instead.
Because we literally can't move forward
unless we solve this problem.
And then the second piece
that came together for us was the thesis
that is definitely becoming true,
true or untrue every single year
that we're on this journey,
that the future of financial services
is very technical.
Engineers are flooding Wall Street.
Every bank is hiring
a 19 year old data scientist right now.
Every hedge funds becoming a quant fund.
And that technical transformation
of the industry is huge.
But these data providers
aren't prepared for it, right?
If you want to consume financial data,
most of these large data vendors
don't even have STKs.
They don't have software
development kits for you.
They have horrible documentation.
Their developer tools are awful.
But we knew that there were
engineers and innovators out there
that had ideas just like us
for an app or a tool
that could bring the industry forward.
If we could find a way to make data
more accessible to them
with the tools they needed,
we could serve that developer market
really, really well,
right at a time where it was about to,
we thought explode,
within financial services.
And that's exactly what happened.
And so, when are we in the timeline
of in terms of years?
What are we talking about now?
So, 2012 and '13, we were building
the engine that we had to kill.
And in 2013 was when we realized
we couldn't afford the data.
2014 was the year that we
really started thinking about data
as a business and doing research
and figuring out how we could start
building our own data feeds.
So, 2014 and 2015,
we were programming a lot,
we were building our technology,
we were getting
our first couple of data feeds built.
And then, it wasn't until 2016
that we really launched publicly.
So, all this time, 2014, 2015,
you still work,
you're still the coder,
you're still the developer,
iterating through understanding.
Okay, now let's pivot
and go into a new business.
Wow, that's pretty cool.
Yeah. Yeah, yeah.
That's very, very cool.
So, my next question was going to be,
then, now you're in 2016,
what have you learned
over those four years
overall about the financial
technology services world?
So, you mentioned the analogy
to the cars and the fuels.
And you can either be building the engine
or you can be building
the data that's fueling it.
But for somebody that's not coming
from the FinTech space,
what are some great insights
that you have from there?
Yeah.
So, some things that we've learned
is that you would be wildly surprised
how far behind this industry is,
technologically.
The for example,
Bloomberg is kind of the household name.
Even if you're not in finance,
you probably know
what a Bloomberg terminal is.
You've heard of the company Bloomberg.
That terminal is built on
14 million lines of Fortran.
Fortran,
which is a programming language
of the oil industry,
stopped using 15 years ago.
But this critical piece of infrastructure
that's used by
hundreds of thousands of traders
all over the world
is built on Fortran, right?
I mean that's just an example of
how these big, big companies
can't move quickly,
even if they wanted to compete
with a company like us.
It's the classic innovator's dilemma.
And it's not even just in the data space.
I mean, you can apply that to lending,
you can apply that to consumer banking,
to  credit cards, to insurance,
to any FinTech vertical.
It's the same thing.
They all have their example
of the Bloomberg Fortran issue.
And its this legacy infrastructure,
where the FinTech are coming in
and trying to break that apart
and modernize it.
But it's not an easy task because
you're also talking about an industry
where you've got a bunch of people
who are really stuck in their ways.
And so convincing them to use
new technologies is not easy.
Right. And obviously,
it's not feasible to convert
14 million lines of code of Fortran
to the equivalent of today's
Python and JavaScript or Ruby.
That's a challenge on its own.
So, how do you go about doing that?
So, you're in 2016,
you're starting to create
these data streams yourself.
And then, we'll end by fast forwarding
to 2020, where now
you're allowing developers actually
to play with this data.
But what does that process look like?
So, I'll tell you a story
about the first data feed that we built
because it'll help you understand
how we approach
building our data products.
One of the core values
that's true to our company
is automation, right.
Where like, we'll never use humans
to do any of this.
Like there has to be
a way to automate it.
And by having that foundation,
it means we can spend more resources
towards making great tools
and we can keep the prices down
and make it accessible.
The more we automate,
the less money we have to spend on that,
the more money we can divert
in other ways.
So, the first dataset
that we ever looked at building
was just financial statement data.
And so, you take
there's all these 10K reports
that are filed at the SEC,
but no two companies
file their financial statements
the same way.
So, if you just went to the SEC
and tried to pull that data down,
Oracle might be reporting
cloud computing revenues,
hardware revenues,
software revenues.
The accountants over at Apple
just put revenues.
So, there is no way to actually compare
apples to apples between companies,
or even over time periods
because companies
change their lines of business.
And so, there's this massive data,
it's in a language called XBRL,
which is an offshoot of XML.
And it's this really nerdy
accounting programming language
that not too many people know about,
but we're experts in it.
Because we said,
wow, there's got to be a way
to use machine learning to clean that.
And so, what the large companies
like Bloomberg do is
they have 10,000 people overseas
that are manually normalizing
all of that data.
We took, my co-founder, who was a CPA,
between the two of us,
both had engineering skills,
and programmed that CPA knowledge
into an engine
that learns from itself over time,
get smarter,
and we take an algorithmic approach
to cleaning all that data.
So, with the two of us,
our data feed number one,
with the two of us,
we were able to build that
equity financial statement data feed
with two people in an algorithm.
And to this day,
it's still the highest selling dataset
on our entire platform.
And so, that's been our approach, right?
Where is the actual
root source of this data?
A lot of it at the SECs,
and then the stock exchanges,
different places like that.
Can we go straight to the roots,
can we clean it and pipe it through
in a much more efficient way,
as automated as we can,
and build great developer
tools around it.
And so, that's what we.
So, what does that mean
to build a great developer tools
around this data?
So, give me some ideas of
where somebody like myself
or any young entrepreneur
who could be using this data
to create some meaningful products.
Yeah.
So, we've got a sandbox environment.
We can get you API
keys within 30 seconds,
which is pretty unprecedented.
If you go talk to any
of the large vendors
they're not going to be that fast.
So, we'll get your API keys,
we'll get your sandbox access.
You can use software development kits
in over six different major languages.
We've got test environments.
We've got Jupiter notebooks
that you can pop open
and start playing around
with the data widgets
that you can test out
with just tons of tools.
Chat support seven days a week.
We just make it easy.
And I think a huge,
huge reason for our success is that
our company was built
by developers for developers .
So, we actually understand.
We were trying to build our own app.
Right?
We know exactly what it takes
to get it off the ground.
And what's interesting is,
a lot of these large vendors
that we compete against
have a major conflict of interest.
They're terrified of people like you
and me because they know
we could build a better app than them.
And so, if they open up those APIs
and those raw data streams,
might somebody maybe build
a better Bloomberg terminal?
So, what they do is
they slap these restrictions on.
That's why we got quoted
as much as we did.
Any time an engineer comes to them
and says, "I want a raw API data feed."
They're not in a position to do it
because it could cannibalize
a whole part of their revenue stream.
So, we've taken the stance of saying,
we want you to build
something cool with this data.
We're never going to be
in the analytics or app building space.
We're just the plumbers.
And our goal is to get the data
Into the hands of these innovators
as fast as we can
so they can build awesome stuff with it.
That makes perfect sense.
But I have to ask,
so you're eight years into this journey,
coming from a very different background
than a tech background,
why stick to financial services?
What is it about this industry
that take you in some way that you say,
okay, I'm going to solve this
no matter what,
even if it's going to take four years
of bootstrapping and writing code myself?
You know, there's,
there's kind of two answers to that.
The first is,
just what I went through, right?
A year of my life.
I'm angry, right?
And then, I'm like there has to be
a better way to fix this
if I want to solve this problem
for other people.
And I'm pissed off
that I learned the hard way.
Hopefully for everybody else,
they don't have to learn that way.
So, that personal attachment
to just that time that I spending,
don't get me wrong,
there's lessons there.
I'm glad I went through that experience.
But
it shouldn't have had to be that way.
Those resources should
have been available to me.
And so, there's that personal story
of what I went through.
And then also, just the pure excitement
of watching our data come alive
inside of some really cool stuff.
I mean, our clients are building
chat bots, AI investing platforms.
They're building
their own trading terminals
risk analytics software,
mobile apps for investing,
some hedge funds.
We can't even see what they're doing,
they just do some deep learning models.
There's awesome stuff.
And we get to be the fuel behind of that.
And so, we just get to see
the little phrase, powered by Internio,
at the bottom of this
next generation of apps.
And so, we get to feel like
we're a driving force
behind changing an industry
that's really far behind technologically.
So, it's fun.
So, you are the fuel.
So you are the fuel to this whole new
21st century generation of tools
that allow others to build apps
based on this data, right?
So, anybody who wants to build a chatbot,
or an any AI machine that allows me
to invest better or get more information,
you're supplying that information.
Because otherwise,
it would be very restrictive
through the Bloomberg terminal
or the likes of the giants, right?
That's the basic premise here.
Exactly.
You nailed it.
Welcome to the sales team.
You're hired.
Very, very cool.
So, now it's 2020.
One of the things that we mentioned
right before starting this is that
you are now getting this out there
to as many developers as possible.
You've partnered with Stanford
to provide Stanford students
with the data to play around with, right?
And that's something
that I'm excited to look at myself.
But what is sort of
the vision for this in the long run
besides just licensing the data?
Yeah, we want to be the
number one go-to data provider
for anybody doing something innovative
in financial services.
Sometimes that is big companies, right?
We have some huge hedge funds
and institutions that have projects
or tools they're building.
But it's more fun when we're selling
to the guys in the couch
that are building something cool.
So, we're expanding constantly
the types of data that we provide
in multiple different directions, right?
So, we're going deeper, which means
what else at the SEC can we extract?
Can we extract risk factors?
Can we go get different types of data?
How can we go deeper here
in the United States
to deliver more US based data feeds?
And then there's broad, right?
Which is,
can we go to different countries?
These financial filings
are everywhere in the world.
Most of them are digitized
and structured and publicly available.
So, where can we take
this tech that we built,
apply it and have a global set
of fundamentals
and another types of data?
We have global pricing data.
But the fundamentals
in the financial statements is
something we'd like to expand on.
So, we're going deeper
in the United States
with different types of US data.
We're going broader
internationally with data.
And then we're also starting to branch
a little bit outside of the quantitative
into the qualitative.
So, obviously there's been a lot
of advancements
in natural language processing
over the past two years.
GPT-3 coming out.
We have a lot of demand
from our customers
who say, "You're giving us
all these great data points
that are quantitative.
But could you give us some
qualitative information?"
"Could you help us search
through the filings
and get other information that way?"
And so, that's kind of where
our R&D efforts are focused right now,
is how can we start to reimagine.
Maybe we don't just have
to be a quantitative data provider,
maybe we start delivering
some intelligence to our clients
that is qualitative as well.
So, those are some of the areas
that we're exploring
and where we're headed next.
That's very, very cool.
So, if you could go back now to 2012
and talk to Rachel back then,
who still bootstrapping
through that first iteration
of building this engine,
what are some high level things
that you would tell her
from the experiences that you've gained
over the last eight years?
You know, that's a tough one.
Because I could write a book
about the mistakes that I've made.
I'm keeping track of them.
And I might do that one day.
But I learned from all of them, you know.
I'm happy that we took the path,
and we did it.
It took those early pivots for us.
It took us solving a bad problem
to find a better problem to solve.
So, I wouldn't change anything.
But I think, just to give myself
a little reassurance,
to say, I always use the phrase:
the roller coaster goes back up again.
There are so many times
when the roller coaster goes down.
And it can feel like
it's time to quit, pack up the bags,
go get a nice job, have health insurance,
different things like that.
And it can be easy to get down
when the roller coaster goes down.
But it always goes back up again.
So, that'll be something
I would reassure myself about.
Because there are definitely
some challenging times early on.
I love that.
You know, 20 minutes go by so fast.
But it's so inspiring for me
to always hear about these journeys.
Especially the eight year journey.
That's incredible.
A lot of investors,
when they look at a pre-seed
or a seed company,
they look at the founders
and they ask themselves, you know,
"Is this a founding team
that I am able to see them
going through an eight year journey
of roller coasters?"
And you know,
that's a very hard question
to answer a lot of the time.
Especially in today's generation,
we keep changing our mind
and moving from one place to another.
So, I think I'm getting
a lot of inspiration from that.
So, Rachel, thank you for sharing
the story with me
and with everybody that's listening here.
And I really appreciate you coming on.
Before we finish,
I have to ask you
the most important question,
three words that you would use
to describe yourself.
Definitely, feisty.
I get told I'm feisty a lot.
I'm definitely fast.
So, I'd say feisty and fast.
And probably, loud.
I am loud a lot, too.
Kind of like a steam engine.
Feisty, fast and loud. I love it,
Rachel, thank you so much.
This is really, really great.
Best of luck with Intrinio.
I look forward to trying
and playing around with it myself
and spreading it
with the Stanford community.
But it sounds like
you're doing a great service
to the FinTech sector.
I am very excited to see where it goes.
Thank you so much for having me.